good yeah it's rock it's rock your [ __ ]
out monday i wanna i want to thank you
guys name-drop monday its name yeah
feelin cuz i saw your Instagram feeling
this can be an hour podcast on what
famous french drop any names and that
that's not the kind of guy I am
what do you what are you even talking
about yeah but I wanna make this clear
what you have one day to tell me about
this party what it one day
not tomorrow what part is today Thursday
Friday Saturday son I went to watch the
fights you mean that one you know with
your good friend who spelled your name
wrong yeah yeah yeah really good friend
and out-build know that picture right
there was when I said to his daughter I
said just take a picture really quickly
while he's looking I want to stick my
head up because there are three legends
on the [ __ ] couch whoa whoa dude four
legends that man on the right will take
you to flavortown love that guy love die
fury he's one of us he's a silly goose
hmm he's uh he made some Wagyu beef
knock your dick on dessert I bet made
some crazy pasta some crab pasta take
you flavortown baby take it to
flavortown it's gonna hit your mouth
take you to flavortown
and he'll die the [ __ ] out you hear
he'll die your hair heal me he's good
now he can cook he was cooking for you
guys he had he had the Sloane girls in
the kitchen helping him out those
daughters
that's correct they were working hard
only thing I give me to that party well
there was no testosterone in that room
at all you got frank grillo joe carnahan
you got you got the great one Sugar Ray
Leonard you got Sylvester Stallone guy
here and no test drive and little R on
the back also there's a ton of
testosterone in that whole room yeah now
D'Elia calls himself a baby in this
picture he is a baby he's a baby he's
probably about 20 years Julie and I are
the only guys in there to fly
commercially who's the chick on the
right she is a friend of somebody there
she's a she's a personal trainer oh god
she's a physical therapist that's cool
really cool and then who's the guy in
the back who doesn't know he works with
guy fury you see he's the he's the he's
the flavortown assist he's the favorite
town assistant do you take me to
flavortown
I've taken a flavor shot told told that
I know now - Jay Glazer razor my my
height was very very tight shirt you
what you're not seeing there's Michael
Strahan my new favorite person did he
not want his picture
taken now he was in he was sitting
closer to I love Michael that's my
favorite person maybe now it's my new
best friend Strahan gonna replace me
with Strahan I would replace you astray
you know you should now now Sugar Ray I
said it would you how do you eat Sugar
Ray looks at me and goes he goes well
how do you how do you stay in shape you
know and I go you know I didn't it I
just try not to eat too much and all
that I go how do you do it he goes I'm
vain
but I'm genetics to for it might the
highlight was when I'm we're all there
waiting in line to eat food and Al
Pacino is there and and my friend Al
Pacino now cuz I've met him twice his
friends my friend she asked him if he's
into Irish men too
well here's what I looked at him and
crystal he was there so I did it for
Chris and I go out look at him and I go
by the way saw the Irishman you were
good you were very good
what'd he say and he started laughing I
go I have notes but I mean yeah of
course Italy it goes get the [ __ ] out of
here Brian yeah and daliyah D'Elia was
when you're a rather all those legends
Dalila commanding us he be he was like
hi I'm avoiding this ha I got I got his
feelings in my chest right now I don't
know I don't know do you know what to do
it's all these famous people you know
it's a little real most famous he comes
up to me Chris comes as we're sitting
down for the fight and there's Harlow
I'm sitting where Chris is sitting and
he walks by me and he goes like this he
was hey if this place blew up you
wouldn't even be mentioned I think
because you'd be it Stallone and Friends
you'd be in France that's he would be in
France that was so funny man 100%
[ __ ] Pacino still got a head set a
hair on him he's got a set of hair and
he's he's the sweetest man in the world
everybody seems to want to fight over
him I bet you know everybody wants to be
around it don't get me wrong there's
some legends in there but the guy if you
had to pick one yeah jeez well what you
didn't see was David Blaine who came in
a little later and sat down next to Al
and we were all around the table and
everybody has their cameras out and he
did some card tricks you know not all
all you guys over 50 are posted on the
gram that's that's right it's pretty sad
now listen I'm tired so I didn't bring
my phone
That's not me I didn't bring my phone in
really I didn't take one picture I never
bring my phone in that house still old
make you leave your phone no brother no
everybody's got their phone out I never
bring my phone and I will never take a
picture that's his daughter who took
that picture she took a bunch of
pictures and sent them to me so I post
them but I had to remember I mean yeah
slide one then the other ones 23 in the
other ones 18 now you don't talk about
his daughters well you know talk about
his daughters but they are all single
and they're all beautiful and they're
all really cool flavortown man I'm not
even allowed to I'm not even allowed to
i'm 52 so i know you not for me nobody's
dan but good girls good girls I said to
him biggest accomplishment is your
daughters because that the group is
Hollywood royalty
yeah and somehow they're all yeah they
Bronte but I like where your head's at
rocky read me read me the first page of
his script on rocky I got on video I was
excited saw by the way
blah blah blah what I what I really
think is aims2 interesting about all of
this is that that might be the end of
the movie star era I don't know if we're
gonna have movie stars the way we did in
the 80s and 90s I'm sure you into
thousands I don't know things are
changing so quickly
David Blaine David Blaine did some magic
for us that would make you question the
laws of physics and make you question
whether or not he's actually Magic Levin
I mean literally he did this trick where
he had I can't even go yeah I'm gonna
have him do this trick away it was so
crazy it was so crazy in front of us
there's no way to tell is he wearing
black new ballots he did he did one
trick where I went I looked at him and I
go like cuz I've known him 30 years ago
how the [ __ ] goes because it took me 12
years to make that work that that took
over Jesus it literally were where he
did the tricking Lou and guy fury goes
all he did is he just looked at me when
Lucifer that's all there's it was the
craziest [ __ ] in the world did is David
still doing shows around Vegas he's
getting ready for a large but is it in
Vegas or you know it's gonna be the TV
thing yeah you hold his breath like
inside an octopus it's gonna be kind of
insane it's gonna be kinda tell you what
it is
uh yeah yeah but I'm not at liberty to
say but when he I see a weird that him
and my older brother look exactly the
same
not yet but we're gonna tell him that
because I want to get him on the podcast
he's in town so where's he live
full-time New York Paris - would see now
but he CJ needs to get a little thinner
Janie's gonna die cuz David Blaine's get
a little skinny now yeah playing gut
yeah I thought Jay would look yeah he's
a better hairline though than Jay what's
he signing this
he sang our guys decks of cards for
magicians he's a stud man yeah
special dude very special knows magic
knows magic now now the interesting
thing about being watching fights with a
lot of actors and people is that there
are a lot of opinions thrown around
I can't watch right now and I love you
yes I want to kill you yes now now but
at least I have a lot of respect for
anybody in the ring right for sure I
still can't do it yeah this I watch
fights on my own right I know that's my
feeling
yeah well I'm a bottom my box now yeah
right yep
and I do Jiu Jitsu with you Machado Yeah
right yep right sure these are my rain
boots
don't look at my rain boots why are you
in long white this is they're my Oh on
the set I gotta run I gotta go I go back
to do some acting very hilarious
yeah now imagine if so you guys watching
the fights critiquing Anthony Joshua
again I mean not me a lot of a lot I'll
tell you what was going around guys
who's won a gold medal in the Olympics
thing box and he's gonna boxing Caesar
by Klitschko came back and won and no no
we know yeah we know
yeah wheelchair changed is imagine if
Styles watching Irish mangled Oh God
Pitino just you're off man yeah I would
approach it like people do that all time
to worse that's fighting cuz where you
want can I throw out just some of the
comments I guess ruin my day
please he's on his bike he's not even
fighting him sell his bike this guy's
not a fighter he's not a good fire he's
not a good fighter Stan he's all hype
standard this is bad stuff what's he
doing he's not even touching him I'm
getting that it's just I'm watching any
worries
it's the same son lastly a [ __ ] boy
comments you see on Twitter and
Instagram yeah he's on his bike smelled
funny you know wasn't saying that you
know wasn't I would have submitted
rising to it's gonna be surprised same
Sugar Ray that beat that be correct so
after the fight everybody's screaming
[ __ ] it was a [ __ ] boring thigh
it's not I he didn't he didn't fight him
this is my later town I'm not gonna say
who he was saying what some people were
quiet and stuff then then me David
Blaine Chris D'Elia
what did flavortown make them oh he made
a sausage and like clams like right yeah
then he made this insane pasta this
white truffle pasta man you know white
truffles ooh and then he may like this
crab this tomato crab like fusilli that
was unbelievable dude flavortown welcome
dude and then this hey did he serve it
and go
welcome to flavortown he didn't say
flavortown but he's you know after
setting the church I didn't know that I
didn't know wave at them but he's a
great dude he said just I've he just had
a bro and loves he's just like he's so
confident his food - he goes you ready
for the Wagyu beef that I've been
simmering says I've been roasting for
two hours that's this [ __ ] yeah and then
he cut that [ __ ] with this with six
different mushrooms on it I was like
well this kid this dude's a beast if fun
gotta get on the podcast actually he's
in know Cal but he's a great guy
I love I just sticks with the hair in
the and they go teach like welcome to
flavortown
have you seen him without it no he looks
so different with a regular gray hair
no there's a photo of him before he
started bleaching into like a character
so he sticks me yeah cuz he's no
definitely his look now I want to do I
want to do two things and I want you to
bring it up holy [ __ ] yeah I don't want
to go to that flavor table but what I
like to see I like the Wow
damn good for him for getting a gimmick
man smart dude oh yeah you can cook his
ass off yeah great personality too yeah
I mean that's what really chefs are a
guy like him yeah
just believes in this product - that's
cool he cooked for you guys yep and then
and then uh then
said this I really meant this to me and
like like puppy dogs like beta males me
playing D'Elia and Grillo are following
Stallone around his house as he's
showing us his paintings his paint I
hope we can paint and he sells them for
impossible amount of money but when you
see it you go like it's so good that you
really don't to be a kiss-ass I'm
already kissing his ass right so you
don't to be like you know man that's
amazing
right but they were so good like all of
us like all of us were like kids I say
if you ever study painting is no no I go
just artist yeah he's an artist he's
just nervous right but you don't think
of that you don't think of Stallone as
an artist lad that way until you see it
did such manly move on genius yeah and
then I looked at Frank Grillo for real
and I was like hey I'm a loser man I
gotta get it together
I need to be more still oh yeah I feel
like I feel like a loser like I'm like
oh job at you flavortown I get paid to I
don't know I would imagine he's creative
dude to go to Rambo 3 horse scene horse
scene Rambo 3 horse scene the horsey -
I'm just mentioned this because I'm
schooled I had to have him I had to have
a fight with my with my jeans trying to
get my pants off I'd have a fight with
my pants
don't ask it'll come out in the day but
I'm wearing pants and I have to get him
on I did 50 takes of that now it's gonna
sound silly but I was sore from that I
was sore I bet a lot going on yeah and
then I asked Stallone if he had any
injuries and he showed me all the
various back operation about his diet
like back then the first place so now he
eats more way more vegetables than he
does meat back then he was a protein
dude he was you know look at his body
here and he's again really riding this
horse in Afghanistan in Afghanistan he
says now he eats mainly vegetables yeah
but I want you to check out this stunt
that he actually really did this it was
this is he did they had real Afghanistan
these guys actually play this game where
they take a goat head or they take a
coat and you have to put it in a circle
you're allowed to whip each other
you're like horses die so there's the
goat now watch is that go too
yes now this is really this is all real
he's doing all of this he's riding
because he's in him he's an expert
horseback rider oh it's a dead goat yeah
and I take a dead goat and that and and
it's a 300 I think it's a 300 yard field
and you have to each team has to put it
get the goat and they fight they bite
they whip each other they take the go
down now this is a term I didn't come up
with it's kids we thought we'd call it
smear the queer well but you see the
horses they're the winner we're really
psyched smear that go yeah horses fall
people die it's a nutty nutty but he's
really riding with these guys does he
write Rambo's - yes he did sir did he
say as bad injuries be oh god he want me
back in fact his shoulders everything oh
you can't make it can you show this part
can you shut out nothing so he really
fell off this Joey movie he fell off the
horse in the say like this again fans
will be honest watches be they won't
know it'll be tiny chop away we can
probably show this part watch that this
is the whole this is the stun I want to
show you how long is this jib the only
two minutes that's almost you're gonna
say watch it's it's now ready watch this
jump watch it that's him dude that's him
it's not easy the two was a fake you see
the finger is so bad no hard to know
definitely hard trick but that's a
little hard to do look at that why'd
they do that everything was all real
tiny now that yeah man he's a badass he
said he only eats vegetables these days
now he eats meat he was mainly vegetable
but he tries to cut down now he's older
he finds it like fish and vegetables is
the best way to eat did you feelin great
I just are watching some of it the
brogan had the vegetarian guy on and the
other guy who's yeah Chris Kresser and
the other guy yeah
the game-changers think my budget in the
argument that was a movie game changer
but it wasn't scientific I watched it it
wasn't scientific it over real annoy you
it's like it was like they took a couple
of vegan athletes a couple out of the
massive group of athletes who and they
even the worst part was they were like
well Conor McGregor was eating two
steaks a day
and Nate Diaz was a vegetarian an
atheist beat him
oh it's like I was like you guys lost me
on this one good you lost me on this and
that interests Rose are arguing they're
like we're about facts I don't but I
would he actually had a lot of good
every doctors yeah I did the vegetarian
guy you knows well yeah the guy that's
involved oh yeah it's kinda like Rogan
homeboy who's going against like met you
first that Syria and that that guy was
ready to go ready to go I want to see it
I want actually really good pot yeah
there's a lot of the Elijah shot there's
a lot of the doctors on there are are
have vegetarian based clinics and make a
lot of money off it I'm not saying
they're not saying that I'm not saying
that you gotta watch me yeah you bring
that up to him and he's just get youth
so I'm so ready to go I think there's a
lot of value in eating a plant-based I
don't think you can just all meat all
the time yeah I don't think eating meat
supplementing meat is a bad thing though
it there's just too too many cultures
throughout the world that live a long
time and are very vibrant that have
eaten meat way more than our vegetarian
I think any diets final in moderation I
think anything there you go got
something doing just plan to the answer
I don't think doing just meets the
answer my moderation is the answer
moderation is the answer be tough to go
just plants man I can't do it wish I
could I wish had the discipline I don't
like it and I never ate a salad in my
[ __ ] life when I didn't want it to be
over I love so never eat a salad in my
life never ate cabbage or any vegetable
where I was like let me get this out of
the way to get to the meat oh I like
Brussels sprouts I don't give a [ __ ]
about yeah you know what I like Brussels
sprouts with bacon otherwise go [ __ ]
yourself and I'm not stopping until I
get that shredded I forgot he's a UFC
fighter yeah yeah executive producers
are all Swartz Nager Wow Lewis Hamilton
there's a lot of big names that even
James Cameron's attached to it too yes
Jackie Chan uh-huh yeah but these guys
come late in life as they're older it's
it's you know as I get older red meat I
drink wine and red mean I'm and if it's
not for in the app it's hard to break
down right box yeah says you
it really does change your end your you
have less enzymes and stuff and you you
do you should probably transfer to a
plant-based diet I can believe that or
at least you have your plants right yeah
yeah I think so I had a ton of meat and
Casey did but it's delicious isn't it a
lot of barbecue
well the meats delicious the problem is
the sugary barbecue sauce you don't feel
like that's my fave I also think if you
cook overcooked meat so for my four
schools I had to eat a bunch of meat I'm
pretending I'm eating buffalo in the
scene and I was but it was I had to eat
it there's little Buffalo no but it was
state but they cooked it like through
and through also it's cuz you can't have
it rushes it's in the thing I left the
nutrients are gone
I don't know I I can't digest that [ __ ]
out it's sat in my face like four
[ __ ] hours no bar do I look like a
nice rib or like brisket like that yeah
it's nice I love uh I'm not I don't I'm
not shot i'm going vegan i would like to
try it i wish i'd the discipline but so
so so did you so you listen to that
debate and weird no I just I got 30 I
got 30 minutes into it but I don't know
I haven't watched the documentary I
don't know any of the facts I was
impressed with how homeboy was defending
his points because it was Rogan that
other dude kind of like taking apart the
documentary boy that dude was ready mmm
he was like bring up slide 101 what you
say
kekeke it bring up slide 303 key key key
you just read me yeah just a car that me
do anyway your mouth oh he's ready to go
you can if you can defend it yeah no
matter I don't need to watch it to know
you know I don't think anyone has the
right answer whatever's best for your
body but I know moderations
Mediterranean diet I mean they the
Italians always ate mostly like the
southern teens because they couldn't
afford me paid mostly that the Greeks do
can I see this you're just gonna piss
you off yes yeah piss you off and maybe
a lot of listeners yeah I'm four
episodes deeper Sopranos leave me it's
all right
I better get better man it better get
better
it sure is [ __ ] better get better eh
better get better and I don't have that
shitty finale it better get better look
at me making me so mad that should make
you dinner again don't do that again
that's what I thought the soprano so far
be respectful now I know it's good
be respectful I'm with you dude four
episodes in I can't remember the four
episode floor first three super slow hey
what do you think of The Sopranos so far
okay I'm waiting and I'm we give it the
full shot but I need you to give it the
full shot but I am a little bit
interested because you've seen so much
good TV that came from it that I wonder
at times if that was the beginning and
then you see like you hear out in John
who's amazing now but then you hear
Christina Aguilera and all the people
that came out of that things do become
I'm not saying Christina I'm not saying
Elton John has some greatness to but it
was bigger when I first came when you're
the first person I do it yeah it's like
tall I know you just like right so
Citizen Kane everybody talks about that
amazing movie citizen go watch this
McCain right now but it with but it's
also like you know you know Irishman you
watch dad the third kind of a gangster
mafia i watch the irish man and i watch
this browns like oh wow well Goodfellas
is the movie I'm just saying you know I
spent skirt just came out yeah he
watched that compromise just the
storyline just like all right no I think
I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure they get kill
I'm giving it shot it's not awful but
it's just like you it's one of the
greatest shows ever so III think you
have to wait yeah I'm holding it yeah
I'm sorry official I had one I don't
remember the first first three were slow
he was talking this therapist he's
having panic attacks attacks yeah
problems with his uncle right all right
not seen it yet man okay yeah I don't
know okay let's see in it yeah yeah you
need to I'm gonna I'm gonna quit this
podcast I think if you don't change your
attitude now now I think you should go
and watch it cuz did the hype and did
the the hype like around it maybe get
tea a little bit it was like came out we
didn't remember when it came out most of
us had a scene that kinda you know I'm
gonna chop man I'm not judging it yeah
but I'm saying the first first floor I'm
just like all right yeah I wonder if cuz
you come here that to narcos season one
okay better than mark okay narcos first
season pretty good do me a favor go back
and watch a first seat of Sopranos then
watch the first narco series and tell me
which is the better show entertainment
life production-wise yeah listen they've
had a lot of time to get it right
they've had 20 years to get it right you
know you want a whole you know what
holds up you know it holds up after all
this time it's changed the way they
shoot comedy and sitcoms hold on Malcolm
in the Middle
you know get out get the [ __ ] out haha
God weird what's how that works out for
sure how many wise yes oh it's a TV show
god no no no that was a young watch that
[ __ ] I know what I'm talking about
so what I thought you would know on it's
a TV show
hold on it's a TV show and it's a comedy
Larry Sanders Oh Garry Shandling yeah
that holds up the writing everything's
funny you oh you'll back watch some
older stuff like all right yeah now
coming out those face pisses not gonna
know it was a game-changer comedic Lee
actually and it came out the same year
my show came out and I was like I
watched that pilot and I watched our
pilot okay what's y'all I'm on I'm on a
shitty show the show inside shorts and I
went I watch that I go oh well that's
the show Todd home I just I can't get
into those shows but outside Larry
Sanders though how dare you
hmm Garry Shandling I've never seen
Malcolm nos all
you know what and I know that and I saw
a thing on the 2000 servers or the 90
you watch some recap of it yeah yeah you
talked about how it was a seminar so but
of course that was my acting teacher
yeah the ball guy right there that was
Mac yeah I just finished I just finished
the Garry Shandling's book that Judd
Apatow wrote yeah it's just like his his
uh his journals and interviews and just
what he's going through when the shows
coming through it's pretty interesting
there's such a beef such a good writer
yeah but his ability to like you know
see what's gonna work and what doesn't
so much of it is like when you're around
those guys they'll be like nah this is -
this is too much but it's really funny
but what's what's crazy with him is
right is he was supposed to replace
Johnny co-hosted for Johnny Carson a
bunch then they're gonna give him his
own Tonight Show and he had a it was to
me at the time to back in the day yet
was 70s 80s it was 2 million a year to
host five nights a week yeah and he's
just like I'm I'm not gonna be happy
doing that huh so he's like I want to do
a show making fun of that yes and
they're like I guess and was actually on
Showtime and so he wrote it based off
that where he could still check the box
from being a host of a Tonight Show but
it was like making fun of that and it
was pretty cool nice guy I met him a
couple of times he seems so [ __ ] sad
you met him later on yeah right yeah he
helps so many people I did a couple
charity stand-up things with him too and
yeah I remember meet him at a charity
thing Kevin Nealon birthday boy yes with
Whitney we went there and it uh he's
just excited towards the end of the road
from there it's tough man well he died
of a heart attack no he actually was
feeling some I think maybe in the end it
was a heart attack yeah but he was
feeling bad and called his like a sister
I was like hey if he had to go to the
hospital the guy's the guy can't do it
today I can take you tomorrow he's like
all right I'm fine I'll wait and then
the next day yeah that heart attack in
his house terrible man damn stud Oh
super stud yeah he had opiates in that
system so talented almost like talented
writers ever
yeah pause I run buzz it's it didn't
string cuz they hit they have all his
journals in there yeah and his life was
forever changed because his older
brother I think was 11 Cisco system died
when he was 12 and they were really
close but his family never addressed it
yeah it was just like his brother died
and then the mom and the dad right they
didn't talk about it so he's like what
the mike brothers gone and his mom like
really focus on the death of his brother
instead of focusing energy on him yeah
so he was the Forgotten child so he had
this huge like chip on the strike hurt
Chelsea Handler's brother died which I
didn't know and I'd known it for a long
time it's like that explains so much
about people changes the trajectory of
you know Elsie you know else who I was
at a party and jared leto was there and
i thought about you because he was
wearing this amazing gosh oh yeah over
here
he's my favorite he's just a lone kind
of done artists in there and I was just
like he was just he's such a house
breath day why I was he breathtaking
he's like seeing a unicorn when it it is
you're some about him do yeah because he
dresses and he dresses in French like
he's just you're like wow but confident
yeah but also he grew up he grew up with
his father committed suicide when he was
8 and my son's 8 my son's a so it made
it endeared me to him so deeply I was I
you don't know anybody stories like and
he went he went to perform an art school
and he grew up with very hippie mom and
and around musicians and they all told
him that it's about being expressive and
being artistic so he grew up saying hey
you got to be a football player at a
tough guy yeah he grew up know masculine
energy I grew up I really did think
about this I read his thing and I was
like look at him look at him I mean he
just loves to decorate himself and
decorate I mean yeah that's his brother
I guess how freeing is that though for
that dude help dope is that for him to
go out of the house and not give a [ __ ]
what you guys thought he wears and then
and then also a lot of people look at
that and get inspired from that now I
would never wear that that's too much
for me I don't have that confidence that
bill to wear that he does though yeah
well I mean he's at the party
everybody's dressed wearing then he's
wearing
you know dude look at him in and out in
that Garry Shandling book I was on the
plane crying there's mmm so his brother
dies when he's 13 no one addresses it
nothing they and I've never said
anything to him it's just kind no
they're just like help then they kept
going and they forgot about him
dude there's so and he never talked
about to anyone anyone on set all his
years didn't mention it but Judd Apatow
went to his house and got his journals
and even jugged goes I don't know if I
if you'd want this out there not by
thought to cement this book you'd be
good before he died he wrote a letter to
his brother dude dude it's a letter to
his brother of what he's done and like
I'm gonna see you so dude I'm talking on
the plane
tearing a horse in coach of course [ __ ]
you're not doing well I'm on my [ __ ]
delayed layover flight from Phoenix just
[ __ ] want to die
I read that oh dude well you know I
think that could you read that it's a
it's a first he's ever addressed talking
how he felt about his brother he was
like in his brother it's been his
because his brother's passing away his
parents won't let him go into the room
to say goodbye dude Wow it's heartbreak
did did you so you you have the letter
it's in the book it's in the book
I got a read I read that book in can you
read that book in two days take that
shirt I'll bring it Wednesday I'll bring
it Wednesday I read the book in two days
I was so into it I read it between my
shows on Friday and Saturday that's
amazing that's amazing yeah man I walked
in closing something there's something
about that like family and stuff like I
this Sunday my daughter sang two songs
with a live band she's been taking voice
lessons and I was expecting it to be
like you know not good you know she's a
kid I was expecting it to be because
there are all these kids they're all new
singers my daughter comes alive when it
comes to an audience and she was so
pretty and she's 11 years old and she
hid a note and she was singing
hopelessly devoted and as she sang the
neverending story good dude I'm telling
you as a man I was sitting there I
started
my daughter I would - I started crying
I'm watching my daughter sing I couldn't
help but I'm literally like like um but
I'm you know me I hate that I'm like
trying to do this oh my god this is I
can't be crying while I watch my
daughter cry but it was amazing but you
can though you know well I took the
microphone right I bumped her out of the
way I took a little bit yeah I did a set
yeah yeah what so it says yeah Judd
Apatow so it's crazy with his journals
cuz he's like you know he's on the road
doing stand-up so he can relate to the
Sam comic he's on the road and he's he
has these offers and he's in the journal
it's kind of like he's so positive in
his words
he's like ego and then people's opinions
he's writing all about it it's very
fascinating especially a guy at his
level yeah anyone he's doing Larry
Sanders she's like you know they want me
to do six more seasons this is it they
don't know yet this is I'm gonna move on
I'm scared to move on but I know the ID
there's more for me out there he's just
making these decisions but he's writing
about in his journal it's so powerful
now like what a stud at the time get man
out of [ __ ] stud mote a Tony Robbins I
think said that most great men or most
great people not just men women and
women kept journals kept a record of
their life feel like less people are
doing it well I think Stan a business
journal I mean if you if you think about
go back and watch it yeah hod casting
yeah I kids can be able to go back and
listen to all this so my dad was a
[ __ ] idiot talk about dicks non-stop
exactly I it says something about every
one of my friends called me goes dude
that podcast money made me laugh so hard
when you guys are talking all out of the
gay guy yeah if I get a copy today I'm
like what if he flatters spit in my
[ __ ] time to be flattered maybe
better before more pissed yeah I don't
think he listens to the fighter and the
kid you'd be surprised
yeah he might dude well a lot of people
do yeah a lot of people do you ain't
lyin brother you know I'm saying uh yeah
I'll give you that book though for sure
I don't see it's do some current events
let's do it man dude the holiday
shopping season is here
whip whip dude gift a gift that makes
everybody happy because everyone's teeth
will be so clean and shiny you want to
just bite into something and have it
basically this thing brushes your teeth
for you okay and by the way with sonic
vibration sonic vibration which kills
the plaque about the timer dude 30
seconds pulses to give you the guide for
the perfect teeth don't overdo it use it
they love it it's a little mine dude
it's a it does send your brush heads
flossing toothpaste they it refills
every three months three million three
million people are already using it
while people getting their teeth right
just go to get quip comm slash fight
this qu IP yes get quip calm slash
fighters save on gift sets and to get
your first refill free with a refill
plan that's get quip dot-com slash
fighter Titan brush baby Biden brush
[ __ ] at how was your weekend though
it's all right did nothing
yeah about you it was pretty cool just
went to go grab some sushi any legit
place there's place in Studio City
closed to sugar fish called dai-chan
it's pretty good
nothing crazy I was tell I've I've been
out Palin raise you everyone's talking
about [ __ ] Popeyes mmm-hmm there's no
way Papa's better inhale and raise your
food I haven't had the Popeyes yet but I
there's no way that's Papa's no yeah the
reason I've had Popeyes I lived in DC I
hate you back and I hate you and I okay
boomer we're talking about the [ __ ]
sandwiches that just came out I had the
ricin being you're texting and the rice
and beans don't give a [ __ ] we've all
had that with the chicken the chicken
we've all had the chip and the job at
this chicken sandwich when the one with
the pickle Popeyes when huh when what do
you when you're lying I'm not lying I
gotta have it you talking about when you
hit the DC went to pot oh I had does
your attack we're talking that you went
exactly I've had the Popeyes there's a
cops I'm just saying there's no new one
how and raise the new one
it's pretty good what gays had a crispy
one with the white meat chicken the only
Chris Chris all right what do you guys
got you don't do the fan submission one
first yeah talk about this yeah you guys
already can talked about this but lit
really everyone kept sending us the
original screenshot of Sylvester
Stallone's photo where he spelled
Brian's last name as Calais thanks Bella
is it Brian first name wrong in last
name and you're the only guy who didn't
spell the name right
hi text his daughter I go your dad
spelled my name wrong I'm getting
roasted by all the fans and she goes oh
no I guess you'll have to change your
name now come back cause I got [ __ ]
great picture though ya see and this is
from ham hunt so somebody went to an art
exhibit in Miami where there was this
Basel thing yeah there was a banana duct
taped to a wall and it was priced to be
sold for a hundred and twenty the first
the first installation was purchased and
then another one was purchased both by
French people the third one was the one
who that was set in the museum this guy
came up there said that he was doing a
performance art piece by taking the
banana off of the wall peeling it and
then eating 120 grand for it it didn't
have to be this guy he's a hutch also
also that that's that's that's the price
tag on that stupid piece of [ __ ] Yan art
it's not art because you do well it's
gonna it's not gonna laugh there's is
what the art piece is the banana and the
tape isn't the art piece the art piece
is the concept of having a banana duct
tape - so how do you of course I'll set
up with ten of them in here yeah it's
you're selling a concept yeah this is my
son run out of ideas
oh there's the Dove and I went to a
modern era place and they had the they
didn't have any art the artist put a
what you would put the art on the
mountain the frame the but the flooring
it was just metal on the floor and that
was those they are yeah and he's a
famous artist Jesus in the modern art
what's on probably so he was so radical
that he is oh there be no art this is
just the the dirty piece of metal that I
mean it's
great when I love that these morons
spend that much money on non art on its
and its non art moderne our most modern
art is all fraud it's all horseshit and
the only reason it's expensive is
because a small group of people with
money not only say it's worth that but
also brokers yeah they said brokers will
say oh that's nice yeah horseshit you
want to watch the clip sure this dumbass
in a minute I hate when they that he did
that to you he has some chicks around
she said this is stupid huh
she works for the museum she was saying
this so stupid why are you eating it
yeah and this third installation was
actually priced at 150 grand yeah a
banana yep great was just some
billionaires and this is all this
tension this is like he's not gonna pay
this market would never stand up in
court
yeah it kind of made me [ __ ] up me
[ __ ] it up and now them hmm don't they
could try to sue him or something but
they won't what are the odds that they
did this as a planned the hardest and
yeah I can see that that's like banks t
selling his real art mm-hmm for like $6
um do you see that yeah he had a bunch
of his real hard in like those third
sheep it's on it's on that it's on
history and he's selling it or like you
know someone gives once hits the jet
yeah but then they just sell it to phone
that he didn't want getting old of it
the way it works although his a lot of
his art didn't sell like they had a lot
of his art the broker and the Hamptons
had his heart there and so far none of
the pieces of sold and they're all on
there for 300 grand for a grant and they
haven't sold cuz you know when a push
comes to shove I don't count much money
you have you're like that's a lot of
money for that you know three I know I'd
be there for Banksy it's just pretty
cool I love his stuff yeah there's some
art is incredible high school yeah if I
had the money I'd have my house to be
full of really great oh yeah me too and
I love great art to men yeah what else
yet so back in 2016 a dentist sent out a
video of him pulling a sedated patients
tooth out of her mouth and he was doing
this while
he was on a hoverboard this is when
hoverboards were everywhere he didn't
think that this was gonna go anywhere he
just sent it to eight people on his
phone and somehow I got out he's now
being sued for like I guess it's
reckless endangerment like malpractice
people are such [ __ ]
and they took the [ __ ] 2000 he did
this job now I would be pissed but I'm
not gonna sue him he still did the job
but also just be a dentist they also
took a closer look into his dentist
practice and found that he was billing
Medicaid at least one point eight
million dollars and now he is being
charged for fraud as well listen you
don't ride a hoverboard as a dentist and
not do some fraudulent [ __ ] of course
you know looking I would say that if you
did this to every doctor and dentist you
probably find that a lot of people are
over billing yeah yeah it's just too
easy yeah but the thing that sucks is
somebody who was sent that video one of
his friends sent that in then or one of
his friends and to a friend and that
friend that day and I can ask most
Anderson Jesus Christ man but he did the
job his job but I can have a job now go
ride hoverboards bro what else you got
um this tiger tuck this woman raised
these Cubs as or raised these Tigers as
Cubs and then they were just kind of
horse playing with each other but
apparently they bit her neck yeah heyo
no she's still alive tiger doing Tiger
shipment look at the size of those
animal oh look at that thing dude you
imagine now you're happy you look up
dumb hey now a dog is scary look at that
head that yellow I don't care they
raised them since they were babies other
Tigers do although she severed
non-life-threatening injuries
well did homeboy die remember uh thick
friggin Roy no he was in bad shape I'm
just thrown up man my little dog my
little Corgi bites me by accident
my head off my core gala hey like ah
[ __ ] you you got a little bite that
thing could buy that thing
well it'll yeah I'll buy it it's like
the guy in India stuck his hand through
the and he had his arm ripped off well
tiger bit his arm yeah dude yeah it's
what they do
yeah that's what that's what though they
do I don't think people realize it's
like this it's like tough guy you get in
a ring with a guy fighter and the guy
does stuff to you you're like or like a
Russian wrestler and you're like what I
felt so weak mmm there's a tiger now the
tiger know who who was it when that lady
was like riding that elephant in
Thailand and I was like Oh mr. Smith it
was like excuse me Oh like rip the hole
well did I tell you about did I tell you
I was in there I didn't see the Tigers
life I think it's an elephant who was
like excuse me excuse me was like oops
and like slip and they were just like
but like rip the entire well I told you
about that that was in that was a that
was at the Laugh Factory the woman had a
cast on and the elephant stepped on her
foot and degloved her foot on accident
though it was skin off the front of her
like when you go through the theater yes
Nick somebody's for you go excuse me
yeah that's what the elephant did was I
excuse me her leg was gone gloved
decocking rip the entire skin muscle off
yeah DK loved her entire foot nothing
just kept on L that would feel good huh
now took all the skin off your foot
skinned your foot over look my bad sorry
sorry excuse me sorry what do they weigh
12 thousand pounds or some crazy
what yeah that elephant oh it's awful
how much do you think it weighs I think
all the weight in the world right now
they're so big I'd say six tons yeah
though there might be more and certainly
you know what they are they're heavy
they're big sometimes just like whether
they weigh the other things heavy [ __ ]
you want 12,000 pounds that's an Asian
elephant
African forest elephant's only weighs
six I was a feat in bush of its weight
13,000 pounds yeah that's that's the
little baby's coming out like 900 though
that's
god they're [ __ ] big and they're cute
ally Alice babies are cute as [ __ ] it
amazing how like human babies that I
mean my son would be [ __ ] without
anybody's help the screwed the screwed
well some of the other animals ready to
go baby elephants all get eaten but
these things can walk on their own and
on their own navigate the world a little
bit and they have any don't need
clothing any other good by the way that
skin I mean Africa I can get down to 30
I mean you can get really cold believe
it or not in the morning so tonight
those elephants are all fine the other
cutest [ __ ] what else you get there's a
few here Ryan Reynolds we got like two
things from my Reynolds so this
barricade almost collapsed on them and
Brazil and you'll see how fast he acted
and how crazy this was what's the
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] watch boom athletic
dude
damn we do the skills of Ryan Reynolds
Deadpool that's Deadpool that's that
Jesus Christ look she's like I got kids
[ __ ] see you
jump to it nice jump
Jesus crazy go that's why you got to
practice your ups I practice jumps with
every workout dude that's that I mean
it's Dipple yeah have you guys we
following the peloton controversy I got
what can help you you just now notice
them these because my eyes hurt
hey Brendan what's up bro listen um
we're friends right yeah yes man I'm Eve
replaces Al Pacino but can take off the
lace oh did you take off the lace shield
they talked about my my traps guys I
gotta be friends with you it's very
difficult for me men can you take off
the lace shield because no man they're
so terrible I can't do that for you you
had to keep maan oh my god is that
velcro's that come off with velcro nope
so how does that work it's tight in
there bro you tied it in Thai didn't do
and you think that's what you know got
those socks too huh drove scouts do they
come with socks nope no separate these
are honey badger socks
shut up to Daniel Ricciardo will never
really be truly as close as we could be
I can't do we just don't see no I we
just don't see eye to eye and just and
you were looking at were you looking at
my socks my white socks but you have the
whole getup is just but that those are
terrible shoes right at least we know
that give that to me oh those are
terrible shoes you don't know shoes no
no I do know shoes cuz I do it for fifty
tears but but those are terrible shoes
we got rain boots on yeah well that it's
90 degrees outside on my rain but am i
right this is black the same thing every
day they look terrible shoes do you you
don't think I wish I could dress like
you're not give a [ __ ] and just wake up
with a same thing do you have to be this
little take they should at least take
this lace shield off nope
can i all right let me just see one
thing no don't try there you are these
shoes these shoes can zip them I want to
see what I don't know no that's a
these are today [ __ ] as to how hard
these ready relax just relax all right
well it's laces do listen to her you
just seen the laces nice you leave it
nicely and open sometimes leave it open
oh my god you're so ridiculous at least
admit you're ridiculous right I mean
these some pretty ridiculous shoes man
traps got customs tough to get now if
you had to sell those on the black
market for a thousand get a grand pharma
paid 200 for them you know they say art
and expensive watches hold their value
very expensive watches papa
well now you're [ __ ] do it cuz your
dumb ass unzip them yeah alright sorry I
unzipped your lace shield that's all
right man again I wish I could just wake
up and go I'm gonna wear this I dressed
like a normal man I mean I mean zero
effort no I dressed for comfort
yeah I know but we're just different
dude you're older I mean I'm young
though spirit spirit spirit I'm spirit
what else yet - I don't know great this
one is but you know of you guys follow
this peloton like controversy I don't
get it they're mad no this is a
different cuz this is a yeah so the
first one the one that they're actually
upset with is they think it's sexist how
does it before saying I gave his wife a
bike sorry
yeah people trying to make that seem
like it's you know so that was wrong
with a guy giving his wife a bike they
lose weight no I mean he he didn't say
lose weight he just gave it to a
thousand dollar bike well mm but what
did what if he did give her her bike to
say hey get in shape this year what's
wrong with that
and it makes Rob likes it easier if my
girl gave me a healthy if my girls like
manners a peloton you're getting thick
and like damn thanks exactly it was so
sensitive so we don't know whether so so
this is considered sexist or something
because you don't want your wife to be
fat the last dad what's this one though
so no that was a controversy that they
thought it was sexist games old whanau
right no there's nothing wrong with this
one no Ryan Reynolds actually hired the
same actress it kind of did the same
play on like what she did after the guy
gave her the bike so it's saying that
she kind of ended it but like broke up
with him or divorced them once she got
sexy no this is just so this is for his
gin commercial Thomas to add a shape but
drink gin yeah basically cool all right
I'll just play so it remembers part two
from the peloton add this gin is really
smooth yeah we can get you another one
if you like you're safe here to new
beginnings
to new beginnings and unnerving video
don't dentists that Lou Cardinale now
that thing goes while riding a
hoverboard you look great by the way I
[Music]
don't give a [ __ ] about that ad I don't
give a [ __ ] about riding around talk
about gin yeah me neither
and some thousand bikes a two thousand
dollar gifts how about saying thank you
a-hole yeah we get it
how about how about how about he's
trying to watch out for your hell yeah
also if my girl's thick and I give you a
peloton should be grateful on saying you
don't have to go to the gym you need it
from the from your house and I'm a girl
gonna be us you know meals are like make
sense yeah I'm allowed to not be
attracted to somebody who's overweight
and want somebody who's not overweight
I'm allowed that too cuz cuz I like
people who are in she also Ryan Reynolds
can make that commercial because his
[ __ ] girls hottish yeah yeah of
course he's like ooh you know hey you
dinner right yeah you wife get off sick
see if you don't give her a [ __ ]
peloton bro you got a problem with it
huh no it's just funny your reactions
are just funny I just think it's crazy
that we're like why this isn't salt
what's insulting no one it's a small
group
they hold cell for sure I don't like
comma Bellator all estimate I guarantee
overweight and don't get laid and ugly
they're probably not that attractive
like this is Regis the husband gives his
wife a bike better better to say they
just don't get laid and can't get laid
typically with the people I wanna get I
don't get the problem is they try to
ruin the game for everybody else mmm-hmm
it's human you want to hate on what you
can't be involved in I get it
I just wish the peloton wouldn't listen
and double down and then the next
commercial for the next year he gets
there like super low cut yeah we all do
this you say if I'm in a party and there
are really famous actors and people I'll
purposely not look over there I'm
purposely done I'm not gonna plant cool
I want to play in a game anyway yeah we
all do that
it's like fashion we just met shake you
don't wanna be I get this gin nice
clothing Russia is now banned from
global sports an Olympics for four years
hold up here's what but Russians are
banned Russia's banned
what does that mean Russia Russia's can
join another country or something oh ok
still though that's is still a big cuz
that's a big sports program Wow not make
sense though right yes
yes stop cheetah yes I mean when it's a
state-sponsored thing you know please
stop cheating yeah and here's the thing
there gene they're not winning last
thing they won I don't know maybe
weightlifting but I think I think stairs
should be allowed in Olympic
powerlifting yeah me too
live steroids in general just let it go
but also Russia quit cheating please we
beg you to quit do you
they're so good at it look that's the
[ __ ] they have scientists even the
Chinese hire the good abs they're so
good at it yeah
and China's oh I didn't I had to try by
the way I think it's hilarious that
China's not included in this they can't
do better cheaters did you see all due
respect the woman that beat that the
Chinese of course you have in the UFC
the Chinese woman that I've got the
world champion yeah
yeah she's that that's natural oh no I'm
saying oh why are you you think she was
artificially created in a lab to become
a world champion I don't think fighter
you want to bring her up though you see
ya seen her next to Henry cejudo hmm
zing the how you pronounce that chin hmm
how does Johnny Johnny Zhang I have no
idea could you speed up everybody in
this room good chance probably she's a
badass you just bring her out I punch
her right in the titty we'll see what's
up I mean you could tell she's buff for
sure yeah yeah you know when you grow up
doing that like Rhonda was pretty jacked
too man
you're thinking different well no I mean
I'm sure the Chinese government isn't
involved oh hey I'm sure there's a
science involved
I don't see where you going there oh
there you go not just the Chinese
they're both are just gone Raj now a
little tank and she [ __ ] her up yeah
god she's jacked son yeah I think she's
a Chinese experiment no I think a lot of
Chinese women are built like that yeah
you don't see a lot of major I mean we
have to get they look by the way by the
way it's possible she could also be what
exactly give her you know it's that
thing where women have also male Oh like
more testosterone yeah yeah inside the
right yes so it's possible that she
could be you know a woman like that now
it's also possible that I'm going to fly
on a hip it's also possible shoes
artificially created a double world
change us trying to say that anything
I'm winded dude yeah yeah she is and I
don't and do I mean tough to be do I
think the Chinese government would has
scientists and ways to beat drug tests
because it's Satan's sponsored no never
yes I'm with you and do I think the
Chinese government would cheat never let
sushi fight next please
hey wait they don't have any male
fighters that figure it out yeah they'll
figure out what UFC I still respect the
[ __ ] out of her I don't backtrack now
buddy you know I still nope you've got
way to make she's a cool-looking human
being no you don't you think she's
artificially created by Chinese a
scientist that's know know what I'm
saying know what I'm father may be very
clear well I'm saying what I'm saying is
I believed that she was been
artificially created by Chinese
scientists that's what I'm saying
I'm not saying that she's the problem
that's what I that's where if I had gone
in my head that's what I'm gonna say you
have yet but only got in my head
otherwise I'm gonna say huh she trains
hard problems for sure what else gets in
I think they are targeting her for you
Annie and Jay check in March oh yeah
great um that's I guess pretty ahead
that's pretty much it you had one more
oh it's just the same young whole coupe
thing but he gets brought up so many
times where he got he recovered the ball
yeah that cuz people are like the Korean
kicker yes he recovered is that is that
a big huge deal yeah he recovered enough
yeah yeah no he's the one actually
recovered a ball I didn't know why was
he in the you know this past weekend
yeah a fumble what does that say right
here catches his own kickoff I've got a
fumble that's cool that's pretty good
that oh yeah it's really cool that's
pretty much it and that Jang is gonna be
playing um middle linebackers etic kids
that's pretty much it
dude I'm off to Atlantic City this
Saturday have you had yourself an
amazing time I've been there I have been
deemed laxity I have been there what
have you done the Borgata
you know I know the Borgata theater and
I know Atlantic City very well I've
never been there right no you haven't
ah well listen it's there and I'll tell
you something in
they they wanted to make it the crown
the jewel of the boardwalk was anyway
why hey why do I think of uh Trump when
I think of it like City we didn't he
have a big hand in laying city he did
comes out here for everybody did that's
why I didn't work out very well for me
both lot of stuff now if you need a
place yeah if you need a place to kill
yourself when you're there please let me
know and I can probably point you in the
right well hopefully I'm not kill myself
um don't worry don't get stabbed there's
a lot of stabbings they call hey man I
got a show there at Lake City this
Saturday Borgata once you're early
Derek and a song will be with me and
then after you watch UFC 245 with me
want to get one show once you're only
Saturday Atlantic City the next week I
think baby Jesus I'm at my favorite
place on earth I would live there if I
could know Hoya Comedy Store
let's basically San Diego you know Hoya
the next Thursday Friday Saturday La
Jolla the economy store then I wrapped
December Oklahoma City two shows one
night that's December 27th then Tulsa a
casino in Tulsa that's that Saturday
December 28th and then January gets
pretty frosty Connecticut Foxwoods
I think it's casino January 10th then
the Wilber Boston almost sold out
January 11th get tix now f @k calm and
then I just added I'm part of the Just
for Laughs comedy festival Vancouver and
globe theatre February 21st dude suck it
Phoenix
December 21st I'll see you at the
celebrity theater and then I got Boston
Wilbur theater New Year's Eve the 31st
of December come see me we're gonna have
some fun T Pat K Tom this the fudge kid
route